your purpose comes from your pain you
don't have to go sit on a Mountaintop
for 20 years to meditate on what your
purpose is your purpose is to help
people who currently are who you used to
be so whatever you came through you
struggled you suffered to get here not
physical pain like you broke your arm or
something like emotional pain when did
you feel just worthless as a human being
go back to that moment and understand
that there are millions of people right
now who currently are 19 year old Evan
facing the same problems and you
represent hope to them like you made it
out you forged your own path and then
just recognizing that there are millions
of 19 year olds around the world that
you could help and will love to help and
so we are we are hardwired to serve
serving hits the same part of your
brains having food and having sex it's
literally hardwired into you as a human
but who do you serve not not everybody
is equal you could you could hold the
door for somebody but it's not the same
as helping somebody who currently is who
you used to be and again that will never
get old need motivation watch your top
10 with believe Nation hey it's Evan
Carmichael and I make these videos
because I need them because I want to
wake up every single day and get pushed
by somebody who's doing a lot more than
me and in watching their videos it
inspires me to be bolder to have more
courage and go chase down the life of my
dreams and I hope it does the same for
you so today let's learn from me and my
team's take on my top 10 rules of
success enjoy
rule number two is lean into discomfort
I do the interview and I was so nervous
going into it that I'm wearing these you
know a thick kind of hoodie that I was
sweating all through like the Tony
interview like oh my God more in the
lead-up but after I'm so hot like I
can't breathe I mean yes we did it but
I'm I'm sweating buckets and so I take
off my shirt to cool off but I have five
minutes until my next show
with somebody else where I'm being
interviewed and so I get on and I forget
to put my hoodie back on so I'm in my
undershirt and
this is what I want to train you and
other people the immediate voice in my
head is oh I need to oh my God look at
myself like we went we started recording
my camera comes on like oh my God
I didn't realize
but then right away it's like no I'm
gonna do this
as opposed the guy would have been fine
to say hey oh my God I'm sorry can I
just put my hoodie on I'm sure he's
gonna say yes right but I want to lean
into that discomfort and so he did the
whole interview in my under shirt
just because
nice yeah
just because now this guy I mean
hopefully this guy gets a unique
interview it's different
um than everybody else uh and so that
that like it's constantly trying to lean
into
those moments whether it's on camera or
not that I'm afraid to do this what am I
afraid of I'm afraid of being judged
right like I mean I could be in my
undershirt all day but I don't want to
be on the in my interest rate in front
of other people right and so because of
that fear I don't want that fear to own
me so I have to step into it and now I
could do it again if I needed to right
it's not an expression of me right like
I don't want to walk around all day in
my undershirt it's an undershirt for a
reason but I could do it if I wanted to
and I don't want that fear to control me
and I think a lot of people don't do
things because of the fear they don't
post to Instagram because of how it
might be judged they don't post a
YouTube because of how people might look
at them they don't ask for that
interview because they might get a no
right
um so every time I feel that fear or
potential embarrassment then I wanna I
wanna step in and do it and worst case
it becomes a great story rule number
three is follow the momentum I think
motivation is like short term so there's
got to be like a long-term solution I
think the key to that is like momentum
because once you start getting wins and
like you start feeling like that high
from winning it like it just kind of it
gets addicting and it's obviously all
starts with small wins like just waking
up when you tell yourself you're gonna
wake up it gets like it gets addictive
because you start to change your
identity for yourself
you start to see yourself as somebody
who's successful who's having success
that's the addictive part it's like I'm
I'm a successful person like I am
starting to get results I feel great
about myself that I'm getting these
results
and so that's why it is this button is
the opposite you're telling yourself
that you suck
telling yourself I don't hit my goals so
you have to be very careful about the
goals you set for yourself to make sure
you follow through and I love momentum
and I think you should if you did
something every day that made yourself
feel proud like I'm proud of myself
today yeah like you guys you're proud of
yourself for doing whatever
and I can't judge what you feel proud of
or not but if you're proud of yourself
every day for doing something whether
you get a result or not just the fact
that you tried to do something and
you're proud of that that builds your
self-respect that creates momentum that
changes your life rule number four is
set your intention what questions do you
tend to ask yourself every day or if
there's just one question what do you
ask yourself
um I think the most important one is
what's my intention for the day so the
first thing that I do is I wake up and
ask what's what's my intention for today
what is today you know so so we're
recording this on a Thursday Thursday is
my public facing day that's when I put
my extrovert hat on and I'm doing
interviews and group meetings and we had
our movement makers this morning yeah
and I had a podcast now I'm on your show
then I'm gonna have to do like it's just
all day long it's going to be interviews
and podcasts and shows and
yesterday was my project day and I just
have the whole day open do whatever I
want and Tuesday is my YouTube day and
tomorrow's my CEO day and when I'm in it
I'm not thinking about what's next like
today all I care about is your show and
what I'm doing right now and then my
next interview I'm going to think about
their show I what am I doing tomorrow I
don't know I mean I know it's CEO day
but I don't even know what I'm supposed
to be doing tomorrow until I get to
tomorrow so I use the morning as a reset
to say
oh what am I what am I doing today oh
today's Thursday okay Thursday I wake up
like I have no idea what I'm doing okay
you know I was like I wake up like what
day is today what am I supposed to be
working on it's not like I wake up and
say I'm ready it's Thursday let's go fam
come on right like I nobody wakes up
like that and so I wake up and I'm uh
you know I don't know what I'm doing and
I look at the calendar and and I look at
what I'm doing for the day so who Am I
who am I having on oh I'm gonna be on a
financial developer oh yeah I love that
guy he was on my YouTube live stream uh
well today's movement makers day awesome
oh and I'm doing this stuff coming up
great and I just want to get myself
ready what's my intention for today I
want to try to bring the best
for all the people that I'm trying to
show up for my intention is to try to be
my best for you here today for every
other you know interview I'm doing for
Movie Makers this morning it's my
intention uh maybe I don't hit it you
know maybe maybe you walk away and say
Evan men that sucked that was the worst
interview I've ever seen you do awesome
it's like it was still my intention to
show up right yeah because when you're
thinking about something else if I'm
here talking to you and I'm thinking
about what I'm doing this weekend I'm
not yeah I'm not here for you I'm not
creating
I think it's disingenuous to the
intention here so in the morning what's
my intention for the day and I'll look
at my calendar and I think your calendar
should be a reflection of your goals
okay right like if you want to
accomplish your goals yeah those habits
that have to happen yeah otherwise it's
just an idea if you don't do anything
right if you just I have all these ideas
of who I want to interview if you're
never reaching out it's never going to
happen so and your calendar has to be
actions that will help you accomplish
your goals also to make sure you're
actually taking action after watching
this video I've designed a special free
worksheet just for this video the
worksheet will highlight all the Lessons
Learned in this video as well as pull
out our three favorite learnings and
quotes that will inspire you to actually
do something the worksheet will also
give you space to write down what your
key takeaways are and your specific plan
of action to make sure you're getting
results if you want the worksheet design
specifically for this video absolutely
for free there's a link in the
description below go click on it and
start building the momentum in your life
and your business I'll see you there
rule number five is believe why is there
so much negativity in the system well
it's because there's a lot of pain in
the system uh when you've been in pain
did you always show up as your best self
did you show up and do things that you
were super proud of when you were
hurting in a lot of pain right probably
not right like you all you come out and
you do a lot of negative things
sometimes and so just understanding that
can can take a lot of the sting out of
people's words this isn't a bad person
this isn't a toxic person they're just
in a lot of pain and we expect people
who are in pain to lash out and do bad
things
um anyway once you figure out what that
who is that serves you for life so if
yours is believed then now you know the
kinds of people who you need on your
team if you're gonna hire a video editor
it's great if they have all the skill
sets of how to cut videos together but
they better love belief they better they
better be a person who likes belief it
doesn't necessarily have to be their who
but it's got to be pretty close so now
you know the kinds of people that you
want to attract into your life you know
the message that you want to put out
there to the world it becomes the lens
through which you see the world and
anytime that you're not happy it's
because there's a lack of belief
somewhere lack of belief in yourself
lack of belief in the relationships
around you lack of belief in the team
members that you've got lack of belief
in the projects that you've got going on
that leads to unhappiness and so it's
also a quick fix we just need to have
more belief in the system for us to be
happy and that's for anybody you figure
out your who it gives you that road map
for happiness for the rest of your life
it doesn't get old like that Tina will
be 120 years old still believing in
other people it's not going to be like
oh this year I'm going to switch it to
something else like no that's who you
are rule number six is build good habits
how do you personally set goals and then
what happens if you don't hit a goal
because like it does happen sometimes
and like obviously what matters is what
you do about it so so here's the thing
so I don't most of my goals are habits
they're not like I want to make x amount
of money by the end of the year it's the
habits right it's the son I want to be
able to lift x amount it's I want to I
want to be spending
I want to make sure I'm waking up at
this time every day it's the habits you
can check out and say I did that
so I think that's where most people mess
up on their goals
it's it's the daily habits you are what
you consistently do it's not about
achieving that outcome it's about being
the person who can achieve that outcome
and that's by setting daily and weekly
consistent habits for yourself if you
don't hit it for some reason
then the big question is are you proud
of the reason why
so I had a guy I'm doing this tour right
now I'm driving in the car between
Sacramento and in Salt Lake City
somewhere in Nevada right now deserts
it's wild
um I had a guy in my Columbus stopped
and he said hey Evan I I have a goal
that I wanna I wanna do six days a week
cold showers okay one day off Saturday
off six days a week cold showers it was
Friday night my workshop he said my
heat's been out all day been at my
girlfriend's house all day or he was off
and so I've been freezing all day long
and so I didn't do my cold shower like I
said I would
should I do my cold shower
I said well are you proud of the reason
why you didn't do it
he said no okay then you have to go take
a cold shower and then tomorrow you have
to take another cold shower even though
it's your day off just to show yourself
what you're capable of
and so when you don't do something it's
are you proud of the reason why not
right so like I'm on this tour right now
90 days 23 cities
I'm I'm two-thirds of the way through as
we're talking
I've committed to going to the cities
I've sold tickets in these different
cities you know if my mom went to the
hospital
tomorrow for something
I would cancel my tour and go home and
be with my mom
I didn't follow through on my goals I
didn't do what I said I was gonna do I'm
disappointing a whole bunch of people
who bought tickets and I do my best to
make it up to them but I'm not going to
make everybody happy like some people
will be pissed at me yeah but am I proud
of the reason why I didn't do my goal
hell yeah so I'm okay with it
right so when you set a goal you have to
follow through and if you don't then
then are you proud of the reason why not
and if you're not then you have to come
back twice as strong the next day just
to show yourself rule number seven is
value your team how do you uh make your
team better
like how do you like to go ahead and try
me improve your team day to day I think
it's it's caring about them as people
wanting them to win as humans more than
you want them to win with you
I want the people in my team to win as
people more than I want them to win with
me
now quite often it's a similar path it's
like hey you want to do this your best
path is to stay with me and I'll help
you get there but it may mean that they
have to leave and go do something else
right like Zan if you watch our our live
stream Zane is my co-host
um I want Zan to win
more than I want him to win with me and
that may mean he has to jump off at some
point and not be my co-host on this
stream if I ever felt like me being with
Zayn on the stream wasn't in his best
interest I would kick him out I would
kick him out it's like Dan I love you
you can't be here anymore you have to go
do that thing
I'm not going to let you stay here you
have to go off and do that thing it's
it's even though he's bringing so much
value to me it's actually holding him
back if I felt I don't feel that way I
think it's great for him but if I did I
pushed him away
towards the thing that he should be
doing and when you when you do that most
people only think what can this person
do for me
when you think what does this person
need and how can I help them
often again this parallel paths
but at some point some people may have
to divert and go do something else maybe
somebody's with you for life maybe
someone's with you for 10 years maybe
someone's with you for 10 months or 10
hours and and they have to go off and do
their thing but while we're together I'm
I just want you to win as a human and
when people feel that you get their not
just their brain
but you get their heart and their soul
rule number eight is learn to monetize I
don't think people grow up with a
healthy perspective on money some people
like you alluded to think money is
everything and and the next person
coming in that's my next purse and
that's my next she's my next suit or
she's my next car or whatever uh and
money is is everything and there's other
people though which I find a lot more in
my community who think money is the root
of all evil right it's actually the love
of money is the root of all evil but it
gets shortened to money is rude of all
evil and so you're afraid to make money
and you think money is bad and money is
you shouldn't make money you have to
make money I think money needs to be
especially if you want to be an
entrepreneur money has to be in your top
five list of priorities
it just can't be number one
but it's not number one thousand either
like you have to learn how to monetize
and make money because if you want to
serve if you're stuck in some job that
you hate and you're only serving for
free on the weekends and evenings you're
limited to how much you can help but if
you can turn this into a full-time
business and then hire people on your
team and now you've got 10 20 100 people
working for you all aligned to this
mission that you're on to save people
right imagine the impact you can have
because you learned how to make money it
just can't be number one so the last
section the book talks about how to turn
those ideas you got that passion you got
the big heart into something I can
actually serve the world but also make
you money rule number nine is discover
your strengths do you believe we're born
to do something or do we just find
something along the way
I think every
every what I call Michael Jordan level
Talent at something
most people never find it
I believe even the greatest basketball
player of all time
isn't Michael Jordan
it's somebody you've never heard of it's
a manager at Starbucks because he never
picked up a basketball
and so he could have been the greatest
of all time and instead he's a manager
at Starbucks
and he's okay with his life instead of
being great at something
and so I don't know you know I don't I
don't know about the words destined or
anything like that but I believe
everybody has that kind of talent you
have genius level Talent at something
and you've got to go and figure out what
that is and it's it's your
responsibility not just to yourself but
to your community to your family the
people around you to the world to then
share it share that gift and so part of
the path to finding it is just trying
things you know maybe not everybody
should be an entrepreneur but everybody
should try it you should try it and see
like did I like that did I was that fun
was that enjoyable do I want to keep
doing that and if it's not great then go
do something else I think too many
people don't try enough things we get
locked into a career path way too soon
and then you don't know how to get off
of it and then the further on you get
the more responsibilities you have the
more difficult it is to jump off and do
your own thing and so I think it's
everybody's responsibility first to
themselves to have a happy life to
figure out what they have Michael Jordan
level Talent at in rule number 10 the
last one before some very special bonus
Clips is start taking risks taking risks
while you're young because a lot of
people don't like understand that like I
mean people that are listening that are
like in christianized spot like we're
young and like we don't have a lot to
worry about like now is the time to take
that risk like if you ever had the
thought of being an entrepreneur I feel
like now is the time to like try it out
because jobs are going to be available
like later down the road yeah I
I think that was
now 38 39 in May great like
if I was in a job that I hated as a 38
39 year old
and I hated my life
now is the time what I'm gonna wait
another 30 years of working for some
company that I ate you know like now is
always the right time that was people
wait for the perfect time it never comes
and then and then you end up in a
retirement home regarding your entire
life so now is always the time
YouTube is a long-form platform this
podcast however long it goes well it's
not a it's not a 40 second clip right I
love data I love making data driven
decisions it might be great to feel a
certain way but I want to see that it
actually has a result 100 right someone
in the conversation great YouTube
YouTube gives you the best data of any
platform so when this video comes out
you'll see in your audience retention
does it there's a curve called the
audience retention curve
where basically you see where people are
leaving the video so at the start it's
100 everybody who watches at zero zero
zero zero they're they're there but then
as the video goes on it says curve
you'll see at some points a sharp curve
where it drops a lot people left
whatever you did there sucked don't do
that again probably a commercial delete
my commercials gotta pay the bills guys
you know but you're gonna eat even
timing around the commercials right if
you do it too soon you might lose a big
percentage of your audience but there'll
also be these magical moments where it's
flat which means nobody left for this
two minute clip nobody left whatever we
were talking about nobody left and then
you'll have some really magical moments
where it goes up how is that possible
people rewinding the clip to watch that
part again
that's what you cut and put your
Instagram we could take these businesses
in different directions like if the goal
is is speaking the key thing is getting
to know the people who are hosting these
events who are the people putting it on
and build a relationship with them the
easiest way to do that is a business F
show so you have them on your show you
already have a podcast it's great I
don't know how you're selecting the
guests that come on your show but now
it's with an intent to I want to get
speaking gigs
from this person or their Network like
are you already thinking about that or
how have you picked I mean the reason I
started the podcast was to have a big
personal development brand podcast and
so my concern in that is that a lot of
the people I get on now are speakers
authors you know coaches that stuff
which I understand I can't Market to
them because they're in the same game
but not to dilute the podcast if that
makes sense so you have two choices
there one you start a different show
geared just towards this or two you find
an angle that it feels right in your
heart yeah to have them on yeah so if
you're looking who's putting on events
for entrepreneurs you can go research
all the events for entrepreneurs uh or
even like I don't know if you go into
sales or if you go into MLM
yeah great so all of those conferences
or people who are selling Insurance like
all of these things they're like pseudo
entrepreneurs insurance people are yeah
they're kind of an unsure but yeah not a
way less risk yeah right yeah real
estate same thing if you're an
entrepreneur but there's like a support
system around it so there's lots of
events happening around those things
yeah
you find lots of all the events you find
Melissa who's organizing them you invite
them on your show to be a guest they
care about personal development yeah
otherwise he wouldn't be putting on
these events true yeah why put on event
for entrepreneur is there real estate
professionals or MLM industry or
whatever yeah they care about this stuff
do you personally connect with them
enough that it feels right in your heart
to have them on the show you can make a
judgment call yeah whether it's a fit
for the main show or you start a
different show around it yeah but that's
gonna be your fastest path to get
speaking gigs right talk to the people
who are hosting the events yeah other
speakers and authors
not that they see it was competition
yeah but they're they're probably going
to take the deals that they like about
for sure you know and they may not
remember you or past like they have lots
of entrepreneur friends and speaker
friends that you may not be the first
person that they call yeah if they want
to turn it down that's right yeah right
so it's not that it's not possible it's
just a much longer road yeah so if you
want to be strategic you can get we want
to get deals for our speaking gig like
that's the fastest way to do it yeah and
it's not that difficult to execute how
you are like connecting with your
followers on a level
um that is adding value to them but is
allowing them to continue to consume
your content one you have to love it
um like I love
connecting with the community
okay so there's a lot of people who who
don't love it and you don't have to do
it right so I remember I was in New York
I was meeting a really big name author
you know New York Times for sale Etc and
I was in town to say hey let's go grab
breakfast so we grab breakfast together
and he said well what are you doing for
the rest of the day it's like I'm gonna
have lunch with another fan who said he
like became a millionaire after watching
my content and then we're going to do an
afternoon meet up at a Starbucks with
you know my fans in New York and we're
just gonna chill at a Starbucks and ask
questions I don't care about seeing New
York I just care about meeting the
people and he said that sounds
exhausting like oh what are you gonna do
it's like I'm gonna go back to my room
and write and he's had tons of success
as a writer right so it's not that one
way is better than the other it's just
that I I love doing it
and so it's tapping into like if that's
where you get your energy from of the
audience that you have and people
listening to you watching you Etc then
that's where the thing needs to be
birthed not from uh this is a good
strategy so I guess I should do it right
so inside of that
I do things like that where I do meetups
in cities when I travel even here
inviting you back it's like you message
me it's like hey what are you doing on
Tuesday you want to come by and do
something you know for Content too and
every day I'll do Instagram questions if
you see my stories I always put a
question and then at the end of the
night my evening routine no matter how
tired I am I'm still like responding to
questions I'll do like 10 questions and
you'll responding yourself yeah it's me
like when I'm helping people I try to do
it with the scalability to it as well
okay so
you know the people who are here today
that I'm helping they're helping but
it's also content so other people can
learn from it hopefully in in your story
right when I'm doing Instagram q a
it's on my story so people can leave a
question I'll answer it for everybody
okay right
um I still do a lot of one-on-ones in
the DMS as well but that there's just
not enough time in the day to hit
everyone even the questions that come in
every day I don't have time yeah to do
everybody but it's more of a heart thing
where it's like I need that as part of
my nightly routine to stay connected to
the work
because otherwise it becomes why am I
doing this stuff you know the numbers
start to blur or not mean much right you
know you had a million or two million or
whatever it's like okay I don't know
what that means but somebody's saying
your video changed my life you saying
you know I've watched your videos for
eight years every day to learn from
somebody new
that that's why I do what I do I need to
feel connected to who I'm
serving or helping
and in doing that then it makes me want
to show up more because if you're just
making videos in your office or you're
just recording a song in the studio and
you can't connect to like who it's going
to actually help at least for me it's
not as powerful people are so scared of
the opinions or like I said they feel
they feel they need to be somebody and
it's so powerful to where you know they
aren't open about it and it's it's when
you're open about it that things start
to open up for you so kind of like when
did you realize that dude many times and
I'm still going through it just on
bigger levels I'm an introvert so that
doesn't come across in my videos and
interviews like this and stuff but but
I'm an introvert so I have no need to
share my story to talk the biggest fight
I get into with my agent who's as you
know tough New York guy is Evan your
problem is you don't want to be famous
like yeah I don't I don't have a need to
be fair you need to get famous for your
message to get heard so how does an
introvert become famous I don't know I'm
trying to figure it out join me on this
journey and we'll see
um Lots man Lots uh from from big things
to little things let's start with a
little one
um I'm at I'm at Tony Robbins event so
Tony I've been working with Tony for the
past
he invites me to his event to sit in his
specific chairman you know seating and
meet him backstage and all this stuff
they have these security guards who are
all around the stage because you can't
get you know somebody jumps on the stage
they have to be there yes they're
rotating right and so as they rotate
around every 20 minutes or so they do a
rotate and and the guy from that corner
comes to the front of the stage and they
they do this little fist bump with each
other
and then and then they rotate onto the
next one so they keep going in this
clockwise Direction every 20 minutes
doing fist bumps so I'm sitting there
and it's like it's happening right in
front of me because I'm in the front row
and uh I was like I'm gonna fist bump
the next security guard I'm going to
fist bump I want to fist bump the next
cutie because just to show some love to
security guards you know like hey you're
important I recognize you
so the next rotation comes around my
heart's beating
so so they come and I put my fist out
like this he looks at it and keeps
walking like I just got I just got
just got it rejected by by the security
guard at Tony Robbins event I can't
believe it my initial instinct is oh my
God I hope nobody like who saw that did
anybody see me just get destroyed here
by the security guard and of course we
always make the story way bigger in our
head than it is like yeah chances are
almost nobody saw it and the ones who
did did they even care and I'm sure like
two people maybe saw it and are laughing
great but in my head it's like everybody
the whole world's hot right
um
and so
in that 20 minutes before the next
security guard fist bump came up I'm
sitting there and reflecting I'm not
even listening to Tony at this point
because I'm I'm stuck in my world about
the Lost fist bump like what do I do
next and and here's the thing that got
me to do the fist bump again
humans are built to serve
humans are built to serve we're wired to
serve like serving and helping others
does the same thing to your brain as
food and sex like we're wired to serve
yep it's human nature it's human nature
human nature yeah and at the same time
we are
afraid of of other people's opinions
judgments expectations and so most
people live life with their their foot
on the gas and the break at the same
time because serving involves other
people you have to help others you have
to do something for others it's not just
serving yourself that doesn't feel good
it's serving other people but if you're
also at the same time afraid of how
they're going to react and judge you
then you never do anything most
entrepreneurs aren't patient enough most
entrepreneurs end up losing their
business they end up shutting down
because they think it's going to happen
in a couple months or even six months or
a year and really it's gonna take them
four years five years before they hit
their Mark they don't have enough
patience they don't allow enough time
for momentum to build up and they quit
and they end up going back to a crappy
job that they hate and maybe never ever
take a shot and get an entrepreneurship
because they feel it's not for them or
really they missed out you missed out on
your destiny you missed someone creating
something amazing
because you just didn't have enough
patience now
I believe in patients in the macro I
believe in patience and knowing it's
going to take a long time I also think
inpatients can serve you greatly but
that's in the micro that's in the daily
the impatience of did I do my best today
did I do my best today can I do better
can I drive more can I drive harder and
knowing that even if I give my best
every single day it's still going to
take time
it's still going to take a number of
years for something to happen I want it
to happen as soon as possible I'm going
to drive and be impatient as crazy to
get it going but I know it's going to
take time too it's embracing both that's
when you start to win I look at my my
YouTube my Instagram my social media
strategy YouTube 7
000 subscribers four years ago 1.2
million subscribers now four years by
making videos every day every day and
I'm impatient as anything because I want
it to be amazing I want to make every
video better than the last and looking
for all the hacks and SEO and thumbnail
strategies and title strategies and all
of the stuff that we're supposed to do
right I'm on top of it and I know that
it's going to take me four years to get
there I know it's going to take me a
while to get to my next two million five
million 10 million I look at Instagram
follow me on my Instagram Journey I'm
starting from nothing you can see how to
build it up from zero I had eight
thousand followers many of you already
have more followers than I do on
Instagram but I'm gonna win I'm gonna
pass people I'm gonna get mine because
I'm going to make daily consistent
content three to four times a day for
four years I'm gonna be impatient as
anything and that the post today has to
be amazing has to be something that I
want to show my grandkids right that's
the intent every time I create anything
I want my grandkids to watch this video
I want grandkids to watch the next
Instagram thing that I put up it's the
best that I can come up with in the
moment and I know it's going to take me
four years maybe three years maybe two
years but it's not gonna take me two
months
I realize it's going to take working
hard and working smart together always
for someone who wants to create this
master morning routine yeah you know
it's one thing to just listen or to see
what other people are doing but how can
they actually create one for themselves
so I split in the two the first part is
what has made you bold powerful
confident alive right it's happened to
you you've felt it it's just not
consistent that's the problem for most
of us it's not consistent of these
moments of boldness like I can do
anything and then you wake up tomorrow's
like I can't do that thing anymore and
we just live in the world of I can't do
it but you feel like you're capable of
more but you're afraid to take action so
in those moments where you have felt
boldness what did you do just before did
you did you have a conversation did you
meditate prayer like whatever the thing
was yeah then that's not even pulling
from somebody else that's you you've
already felt boldness what happened how
did you do it now try to plan that in
your morning routine and that can be
different for other people for me it's
helping people and so the easiest way to
do it is by going live on Instagram
um then it's pulling from different
people to see what are they doing and
how can you apply it I love small tests
yeah we were talking about journaling
before yeah before I went live
um so a lot of people do journaling Tim
ferriss's journaling like lots of
successful entrepreneurs do drilling so
okay I'm gonna great idea to action I'm
huge and I get an idea go do something
about it yes we have a big mission to
change the world right I mean and it's
like okay our immediate goal I need and
maybe we hit that in a couple months
doesn't have to it doesn't have to take
the December to
if you have 10 clients who are still
over happy too right very much so but
the immediate goal is it's not some
crazy thing that you're coming in to say
I need to have right a thousand clients
paying me right yeah so it's five
clients five clients between now and the
December right yeah perfect at a minimum
so then it's who are the best people who
can afford you yeah to pay two thousand
dollars a month if you're calculated
with women then we could find it's women
it's not that you only have to do one
but it's helpful to yeah narrow in on
like the right influences to take you to
the path right so
is it women in careers so I've honestly
mostly been haven't coached any woman oh
I've been coaching men okay
um and it's been the people who I have
been coaching are people that are in the
um like in the fitness space so it's
more of a figuring who are the people
who have budget who can hire you or you
get paid to
come in to an organization and help them
with their team yeah exactly honestly
like as I think more about this it's
like how can I create the Maximum Impact
right not yet
Maximum Impact yeah yeah it doesn't make
you money in the next three years well
that's true and we need we have a drop
dead date December 33. yes yes you're
right and right yeah so but that's not
the question right now Maximum Impact we
just need impact right Max of impact on
like individuals but not world oh yes
high impact and we need to be paid to do
it so we can continue to build and scale
okay
I think people who are going to be
entrepreneurs is a really hard Market
because they just don't have
budget right and especially if they quit
their job and then they go to start
their business then they have no more
money to pay you yeah so the coaching
will probably end absolutely so it's
finding people who are it could be if
you're making a quarter million plus a
year and you want to start a business
yeah you know I'm good I'm I'm gonna
help you
and I would get the 25k up front
once they start the business it's going
to be really hard to yeah right and I
collect after every session okay yeah up
front yeah like all of that it could be
a potentially negotiable right could I
do quarterly installments could I do
just six months you don't have to say no
to it but you can say like here's yeah
here's here's what we did doing the work
is torture for most people
if you look at my channel we're doing
three videos a day for a lot of people
jumping into my work schedule would be
torture for them it would be torturous
like it's just too much work right and
that's great and it's like I love it
though like I chose I chose this life I
love the work I'm doing I love being
here talking to dick you know this is
this is good this is happy for me other
people like I gotta talk to dick I got
to be on a live stream I'm panicking I'm
freaking out you put me in that
landscaping job I had a landscaping job
I would die man like I hated that job
like you know what I love being outside
I love I love being fit I love my
friends here like it's just to be
successful in anything you have to enjoy
the work that you're doing and not
everything is great you know not every
day is roses you're gonna have a lot of
crap that you deal with and the thing
that gets you through all the crap is
just the love for the process and so I
think it's still important to have goals
it's nice but more important than the
goal is the journey to get there and
you're just getting started in all of
this right yes
the opportunity here is
there's the big long-term opportunity of
you could help whether it's everybody
whether it's women whether female of
color or whatever that says a lot of
people in
even just North America who need that
yeah
the immediate opportunity is figuring
out okay how do we how do we replace our
salary correct because the the women on
the train may not be able to afford you
as a coach right right so this is where
a lot of people get stuck right at the
beginning I love these people and
they're so good like you didn't want to
help and then you get you get pulled in
to either helping them for free or doing
it like super discounted rate yeah and
you feel so fulfilling but it's like you
are not making money right so it's it's
just an order of sequencing so it's not
that you'll you're not able to help
those women in a deep way it's just not
now right because now is we need to
prioritize within our mission making
money
so that we can afford to quit our job
and then make more money so we can
afford to hire team to help us build our
brain so like on purpose first yes you
have to learn how to monetize right
right number one is Mission purpose and
then somewhere in two to five has to be
making money if you're an entrepreneur
or you don't make money tell us what is
one thing you do every morning to set
your day up for success
um
I've got a bunch I'm trying to think
like what would be a really cool or
different one
um
thinking about service right like
it's so easy to get complacent as an
achiever
so thinking about like what I do today
has to matter I want to create something
meaningful that's going to help impact
other people's lives today and putting
that pressure like tomorrow is a
different day today something important
has to happen giving has to be a part of
the morning routine
oh okay
I might have to think about that yeah
whether that's whether that's actually
given in terms of like
you're going to take a call with
somebody and Mentor them uh or you're
going to buy the coffee for the person
behind you in line or you're just gonna
meditate and pray for somebody like I'm
thinking of somebody in my head and I
want them to have love today and you're
like focusing your energy on supporting
somebody else
giving will make you feel so much more
alive and has to be a part of your daily
routine whatever you want to sell show
me the process of you doing it so if you
don't have an email list yet you can
even look at who's following you on
Instagram and message people and say hey
I'm going to do a free coaching session
for people who wants 25 minutes of my
time for free to talk about coaching
whatever issue you have you're an
entrepreneur whatever confidence issue
you're facing right now I will Coach you
for free but it's going to be online
okay those are two different shows
though the biz Dev show is we're trying
to build a relationship with a potential
client and get them on the show to tell
their story but then inject a little bit
of what you do 25 of the show is about
you and confidence coaching helping them
the second show is just a straight up
coaching show where they know they're
coming on
but they may not be in they may not be
an ideal client for you which is anybody
who needs okay okay
because I need I want to see that you're
a good coach because you can talk and
you can give me your Frameworks XYZ and
you can you can have all of your
material you can but that makes a good
speaker
how do I know if you're a good coach
right like Ted Williams was a great
baseball player but he wasn't a great
coach so you could be a great speaker it
doesn't mean you're a good coach so how
do I know if you're a good coach I need
to see you coach
so you that's a that's a separate series
on the channel so now we're splitting it
up between the biz Dev show where we're
trying to get clients and a coaching
show where we're we don't care if
they're ideal clients are not coming on
We're just trying to show coaching and
help them of course and help them and
then if you have your website or you
build out your funnel that then becomes
content so when somebody lands on your
hey hire Frankie to be your coach I can
see examples of what you do and how you
coach people how are you able to
overcome those barriers that were kind
of those limiting beliefs that are maybe
holding you back from becoming the
thought leader inspirational person that
you wanted to be that you are now the
starting point for me really was I
always focus on who I was serving
instead of who I wasn't most of the time
we're focused on who we're not yet well
why don't I have I've got what three and
a half million subscribers now why isn't
it five or like 50 or 100 or billion you
know it's like it's always who are we
not and so at the beginning we really
struggle to get going because 25 people
watched your video and you feel like a
total failure especially if you've had
success in a different field if you had
all the success in real estate investing
and then you make a YouTube video and 25
people watch it it's like that's rough
yeah it feels like you've already tasted
success it's really hard to start at the
beginning of something new we feel like
I've got information I've got good no I
should I should be doing better than
this I just always Focus though on who I
was serving and who I wasn't when I
started on YouTube
I'd already sold my company I already
had my first exit I was already in the
Venture Capital game as well so we
already had some success I was just
doing it to try to give back and serve
and help and so if 25 people saw the
video like hey that's 25 people who saw
the video that's 25 people for one
person I might be a life-changing video
and I just always focused on who I was
serving instead of who I wasn't and and
it grew to the point where they started
recommending and referring and I
understood the algorithm a little bit
better and YouTube caught up to being an
educational platform
um but if you can focus on that that hey
I did 25 today and I did 28 tomorrow and
I did 35 the next day it's like this the
growth curve starts to take off for you
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome for 10
more amazing rules from Tom bill you
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there once you decide
to believe that you can learn anything
your life will change forever because
most people believe their talent and
intelligence are fixed traits and that
life's just about making the best of the
hand that you were dealt the amount that
you can learn